uh but we are hearing in that it's gone
up to five percent and I suppose with
that result some may worry does that
show the bank is panicking yeah that is
a very very significant move indeed I
think the banks and the monetary policy
committee's hand Jane has obviously been
forced by those very uh disappointing
inflation uh May figures that we got
yesterday I think the bank has decided
they had no option really if you think
about the fact that inflation in May was
8.7 well that remains more than four
times the uh the target rate of the uh
of two percent of the monetary policy
committee is Target is mandated to
Target and uh they feel obviously they
have had very little choice in the
matter what is uh really quite
interesting there is that there's been a
body of the monetary policy committee uh
who uh were against raising interest
rates I'm looking here Jane at the uh
the press release at the bank of England
has put out it was a majority seven to
two vote uh to raise bank rate by half
of one percent so you don't have to be a
genius to know who voted against raising
interest rates that would have been
Silvana tanrano and Swati dengra who
were the uh Doves on the monetary policy
committee what is really really
interesting is that all the other
members of the MPC voted to go by half
of one percent there was a bit of
speculation in the market that you might
see a three-way split that you might see
some members voting to go by just a
quarter of one percent so the fact that
the vast majority have gone for that
High Point rise is very very interesting
I can read you Jane a bit of the uh
commentary that we're getting here from
the bank of England they are noting uh
here they say business surveys continue
to uh suggest underlying quarterly GDP
growth of the Rand quarter one percent
household spending has strengthened a
little uh but it's this it's this
question about earnings that I was
talking about a moment ago Jane that is
what's really uh forced the bank of
England's hand here the fact I mentioned
it just before we got that decision uh
average earnings increased by 6.7.6
percent in the three months to April
that was above the bank's expectations
when it last issued its quarterly
inflation report and the bank goes on to
say in this statement here three months
on three-month growth in this measure of
pay has also picked up now the banks
suggesting that earnings growth is going
to ease over the course of this year but
it's really the fact that you've got
these persistent inflationary pressures
they're talking here in the statement
about core inflation now we were talking
about this time yesterday call inflation
is the measure of inflation that strips
that volatile elements such as food and
drink alcohol and tobacco and that
actually Rose uh in May from 6.8 percent
to 7.1 percent and that was another real
indication that inflation is becoming
entrenched in the UK economy and that is
addressed squarely here in the monetary
policy committee's statements uh they're
saying that uh core price Goods price
inflation has been much stronger than
projected uh it goes on to say here um
that they expect CPI inflation to fall
significantly further during the course
of the Year well we've heard that from
the bank of England before and it hasn't
really materialized so far today the
bank reiterating here CPI inflation is
expected to decline later this year uh
they're talking about food price
inflation in particular which they say
they think will fall further in coming
months but here is the key statement I
think Jane the NPC's remit is clear that
the inflation Target applies at all
times reflecting the Primacy of price
stability in the UK monetary policy
framework the framework recognizes that
there will be occasions where inflation
will depart from the target as a result
of shocks and disturbances monetary
policy will ensure that CPI inflation
returns to the two percent Target
sustainably in the medium term the MPC
recognizes and here's the crucial bit
Jane that the second round effects in
domestic price and wage developments
generated by external cost shocks are
likely to take longer to unwind than
they did to emerge there has been
significant upside news in recent data
that indicates more persistence in the
inflation process against the background
of a tight labor market and continued
resilience in demand and accordingly the
committee voted to raise bank rate by
half of one percent to five percent the
MPC will continue to monitor closely
indications of persistent inflationary
pressures in the economy as a whole
including the tightness of labor market
conditions and the behavior of wage
growth and services price inflation and
I think this is the bit that will alarm
a lot of people if there were to be
evidence of more persistent pressures
then further tightening in monetary
policy would be required and that is
something that the bank has hinted at
it's certainly what's being priced in by
money markets you recall earlier on this
morning Jane when we were chatting about
this I mentioned that the the market is
now pricing in a terminal rate which in
the jargon is the point at which
interest rates Peak during the current
rate tightening cycle well the market is
pricing that in now at close to six
percent so even from here we have quite
a long way to go big big moment this the
13th consecutive interest rate rise from
the bank of England since it began
raising rates back in December 2010